now first
let me just say that i'm encouraged that
so many of you from the republican party
have agreed to meet me in this way
now as you know i've tried very hard to
reach across the aisle
and govern this country from the middle
well oh due respect
mr president we disagree with you
we think you should run the country from
not the middle well that's why we're
here
uh if you would i'd just appreciate some
feedback on some new ideas and
directions for this country
feel free to agree or disagree
whatever you want we're gonna disagree
disagree disagree
first i think the government is too big
i think we need to shrink the size of
the federal government so that all
decisions can be made at the state level
we disagree mr president
you drive a hard bargain you win
there we go big
government it is
next up this has been a hot button issue
but i think we can settle it right here
no taxes for rich people we completely
disagree
round two goes to you guys
okay more taxes for the rich
okay what the what is happening
to us man i am taking a beating here
guys
all right last issue immigration now
we need to secure our borders and
anybody who's here illegally should be
hunted down
and deported
if we disagree
[Music]
we are a country of immigrants no we
need a clear
path to citizenship for all of those who
are already here
[Applause]
[Music]
great i love your ideas lastly we cannot
regulate
firearms
yes we can we're good
all right all right you guys say so
nobody better throw me a cigarette
ain't i a stinker
you